tag 3 der ukrainischen gegen offensive
im süden des landes in der region carson
und erstmals haben wir jetzt aufnahmen
dieser ukrainischen einheiten beat dort
versuchen vorzudringen wir sehen uns das
einfach mal an hier sehen wir die
ukrainische einheiten die also ja ihren
panzern alles gute wünschen auf den weg
nach vorne da haben wir tee 64 grad
gesehen hier links aus italien gebrachte
gepanzerte fahrzeuge vom typ iveco lmv
da sehen wir weitere panzer die hier
sich bewegen in richtung front das ein
sehr moderner t 84 der ukrainischen
armee und wir gucken uns das ganze mal
hier weiter an die soldaten haben also
relativ gute stimmung bei aufnahmen von
gestern oder vorgestern und wir sehen am
ende auch wie sie sich auf ihren
schützenpanzern und zwar auf sogenannten
bmp 1 hieraus sowie etlichen beständen
nach vorne bewegen sind also teilweise
westliche waffen teilweise eben auch
wahrscheinlich aus westlichen staaten
aus polen zum beispiel gesponserte so
wertig waffen mit denen sie hier sich
bewegen die situation am boden sieht
nicht besonders berauschend aus für die
ukrainische armee auch wenn die gegen
sie wird dort gegen die russische
besatzung seit drei tagen jetzt andauert
hat man bisher nur kleine geländegewinne
etwa hier und hier erzielt das ziel wir
hatten das schon gesagt ist eben diese
gesamte region nördlich das thema also
diese gesamte region erst einmal
abzuschneiden von der russischen
versorgung das wird jeden tag schon
gemacht und dann einzunehmen luca nahm
das bisher nicht geschafft und müssen
also weiter die versorgungswege
bombardieren auch da haben wir neue
aufnahmen von gestern von der antonov
ski brücke das ist eine der letzten
brücken über den den rp die von russland
beherrscht wird und dort gibt es
weiterhin wir sehen uns hier schwere
ukrainische angriffe mit den sogenannten
heim us-raketen also amerikanischen
raketen eben auf diese brücke um dort
wir sehen es hier schon sehr zerstört
und sehr dünn aber sie steht eben immer
noch aber um dort jegliche möglichkeit
den russen zu nehmen weiteren von der
krim und aus russland nachschub run zu
holen wir müssen aber auch in den osten
des landes gucken dort gibt es keine
ukrainische gegenoffensive sondern
weiterhin eine russische offensive und
wir gucken uns aufnahmen an aus der
stadt lübz kaya wie luca noch sky liegt
ungefähr hier also auch noch gerade so
in der region donetsk das ganze ist die
region donetsk dort versuchen die russen
weiter vorzudringen und wir sehen
einfach mal wie sie das weiterhin machen
mit welcher mit welcher unglaublichen
feuerkraft wir sehen hier zwei bm 21
system der russischen armee feuern
jeweils 41 raketen also 82 raketen
abschießen und wir sehen dann auch
relativ genau wie sie die stadt nämlich
treffen hierbei den verteidigungsanlagen
ganz im süden der stadt da wo die russen
also vordringen wollen wo sie in diese
stadt hinein wollen sehen wir immer mehr
explosionen genau auf diesen
verteidigungsanlagen und es bleibt das
gleiche problem für die ukraine im osten
wie auch im süden des landes die russen
haben weiterhin eine extreme feuerkraft
im süden ist sie gerade mehr oder
weniger ausgeglichen im osten das wissen
wir aus ukrainischen quellen es gibt
teilweise immer noch zehn zu eins für
russland also zehnmal mehr feuerkraft
wir sehen das im hintergrund für
russland als für die ukraine und wir
können das ja ganz kurz noch mal
angucken das hier sind also 4g stöckige
häuser die hier immer wieder getroffen
werden auf den immer mehr raketen
eingeschlagen hat sich die fenster
vielleicht ganz in der mitte und man
kann sich ja nur vorstellen wie schlimm
die situation dort für die verteidiger
ist wie schlimm die situation dort für
die ukrainischen soldaten sind ist die
die stadt dort verteidigen wollen die
haben also ja bei so einem starken
beschuss kann man sich natürlich denken
vielleicht nur mittlere
überlebenschancen insofern ist die
situation weiterhin sehr kompliziert im
süden ein ja ein patt mit vielleicht
leichten vorteilen der ukraine wo sie
auch vordringen möchte im osten auch
einen part wenn man sich die frontlinie
ansieht allerdings mit weiteren
versuchen der russischen armee eben mit
massiver feuerkraft hier in der region
donetsk weiter vorzudringen
[Musik]